Knowledge-based AI is a collection of three things.
Knowledge representations, problem solving techniques and architectures.
We have already look at one knowledge representation, semantic networks.
We have not so far looked at problem solving methods or architectures.
Today, I'd like to start by talking about the problem solving method.
Let us illustrate the problem solving method of generate and test with the same
examples that we have discussed earlier. When we were discussing this example in
the case of semantic networks, we simply came up with various states and
pruned some of them without saying about how an AI agent would know what states
to prune. So imagine that we have a generator that takes the initial state and
from that initial or current state, generates all the possible successive
states. For now, imagine it's not a very smart generator, it's a dumb generator.
So it generates all the possible states. So the generator test method not only
has a generator but also has a tester. The tester looks at all the possible
states the generator has generated and removes some of them. For now, let's also
assume that the tester is is dumb as well. And so the tester is removes only
those states that are are clearly illegal based on the specific of the problem.
Namely, that one cannot have more prisoners than guards on either back.
So the first and the third states are removed by the tester.